Now a second choice is reusing the remote object class that's available in the
Java distributed object model. As before, the
developer writes the bank account object providing
the methods for deposit, withdrawal and balance
and publishes the methods that are in
the object using the remote interface. So
that, this bank account interface now becomes
available for any client that wants to
access that object. The reason this interface becomes
available to the client is because you're
extending this remote interface class that's available in
the distributed object model of Java. However,
note how the bank account implementation is actually
derived. It is derived from the Java built
in classes for remote object, and remote server.
So, you extend the remote object and the remote server in order to
get this bank account implementation object. Now,
when you derived your bank account implementation
object from the built in distributed object model of Java, namely the remote
object and the remote server classes. Now
when you instantiate your bank account implementation
object, it becomes instantly visible to the network
clients. You don't have to do any of
the heavy lifting. So once the public methods
for the bank account implementation are written by inheriting
these built-in classes of Java, all the way
starting from the remote interface, the remote object
and the remote server. When the bank account
implementation object is instantiated the server becomes instantly visible,
magically visible to remote clients through the
Java runtime system. That's the power of the
distributed object model of Java. So the
second choice of reusing remote object class in
order to derive this implementation results in
the heavy lifting being done by the Java
magic. So, all of the heavy lifting
needed to make this bank account implementation object
visible to network clients is being done by the Java runtime.
Now that I've given you the difference between the two choices,
one using remote interface, and the other deriving your object from
the remote object from the remote server. Time for a quiz.